um so yeah I'm Nathan Epstein I'm a data
scientist in web developer from New York
these are some places you can find me on
the Internet if you want to reach out
and talk about anything that I'm going
to talk about here so basically my talk
is a machine learning at scale and so
basically what that entails is going to
be trying to understand some of the
tools in the ecosystem for doing machine
learning with big data and then
hopefully being able to get off the
ground with applying some of those
models to two large datasets on a remote
server cluster so the ideal audience
member is probably somebody that knows
about is aware of spark AWS ml lib and
is sort of familiar with scikit-learn
but hasn't necessarily deployed sort of
these big data tools and production so
you know if you're already working at a
company where you are running large
machine learning jobs on an AWS cluster
this is probably going to be pretty
familiar um so tools i'm going to talk
about our AWS spark ml lib the Hadoop
distributed file system and optionally
flint rock and I'll run through sort of
talking about what each of these tools
are so AWS is a suite of cloud computing
services that Amazon makes available on
demand and within AWS there are a couple
of tools that are sort of germane to our
purposes here so the first is ec2 which
is rentable virtual computers that you
can run pretty much whatever application
on elastic mapreduce which is a managed
to do framework to distribute and
process data across a cluster of ec2
instances s3 which is basically just
very
and reliable cloud storage and spark
which is an open source cluster
computing framework so it's written in
Java and Scala but it's available for
Python and are as well and so in the
context of this talk will be talking
about using it with Python then ml lib
which is a machine learning library
built on top of spark again has a P is
for Python as well as several other
languages and while there are some
subtle differences between the api's 4ml
lip and scikit-learn the basic structure
of how they work and how to use them
should be pretty familiar to anybody
that already has experience working with
scikit-learn so the Hadoop distributed
file system is a cluster file system and
so it's highly fault tolerant and also
allows for high bandwidth for processing
large data files quickly and then the
last tool in this stack which again is
optional is flint rock which is a
command-line tool for managing spark
clusters on AWS atos also has a
command-line tool it also has a web
console if you prefer doing it that way
I mention flint rock as I find it very
easy to use and but it's one of sort of
many replaceable pieces for its part in
the stack um so before I go to the next
slide I should mention I was without
Wi-Fi for a a part of putting this
presentation together and so there will
be several very crude hand drawings as a
as a piece and with that our first um so
basically just to make sure everybody's
clear on sort of the stack that we're
working with we have from our local
machine flint rock which is used to
manage an AWS cluster and on that AWS
cluster is the Hadoop distributed file
system spark which access
is that file system ml lib which is used
to build machine learning models on top
of spark and then your code which uses
these things to build specific
applications um ok so crash course in
spark there's the resilient distributed
data set partitioning and array methods
so the rdd is sort of the central data
structure and spark and basically what
it is is it allows for common array type
methods to be performed over a data set
which is distributed over a cluster of
machines so basically it will take your
data set distribute this over the
cluster that you are using and allow you
to perform common operations in a way
such that the parallel ISM is abstracted
away from you so partitioning which is
basically how we read in a data set and
partition it across a server cluster um
so we can either parallel lies a list
that we have locally as in that first
example in which case a spark will
create an RDD or another RTD in which we
could read in from a text file in which
case each line of the the file is
processed as an element of that our DD
and then we can recollect the elements
that are distributed across the cluster
of nodes by calling collect and that
will return a list uh generally it's
considered pretty dangerous to do this
unless you're sort of very clear about
you having reduced an RDD to a size
that's manageable because the whole
point of using our dd's and distributed
computing in general is that having all
of your data on a single node is too
much and so you can wind up getting into
trouble as a warning um drawing number
two um so this is basically just for
accrued visualization of the
parallelization that happens we say if
I've got a three node cluster then I
call parallel eyes on my list and it'll
break up this list into a bunch of
smaller lists and send a piece to
different nodes in the cluster so that
we have smaller more manageable data
sets on each of these notes obviously
this example is kind of silly because a
five element list is totally manageable
on a single node but you can imagine if
this list was much longer than breaking
it up into these pieces would be
important to do okay so array methods um
these are methods that are hopefully
familiar um and I have array in big
quotes because we're not actually
operating on an array but the rdd allows
us to abstract that fact away and
basically treat it as if it's a single
date of structure in a single location
and not have to worry about the fact
that all of our values are distributed
across a lot of nodes so in the first
case array map um it's very similar to
the syntax of Python map operations on
lists but rather than passing in a list
you're calling it as a method of the rdb
and then you simply pass the lambda to
that method so in this example where we
say our lambda is just going to be x
times to our rtd is distributed across
the three nodes and on each individual
node we do the mapping so that in the
rdd that this returns we have values two
and four on one node 6 on another eight
and ten on another node and again
because we're doing this mapping in
parallel each node has less work to do
and so we can do it faster and then if
we were to call collect on that our DD
it would return the list that you see at
the bottom of that um reduce fairly
similar um so we have our our DD
distributed across our three nodes we
call passive lambda
with our function which is just gonna be
add two values together and then it
performs the reduce function on each of
the individual nodes to get the values
three three and nine and then a reduce
again across the output values of those
nodes to get a final a value of 15 which
would be the sum of the ballistic we're
looking at and filter I think the idea
is pretty clear at this point but so the
lambda we're passing is just to check if
a value is even we filter the individual
lists on each node and then the filtered
rdd at the end if we collect it is just
too for the even values from the the two
separate our dd's that have even values
chaining works basically the way you
would expect based on that so you can
call a chain of these methods on an
individual RTD so filter for the even
numbers then map them to double and then
reduce them by adding would give you 12
which is the doubling of 2 and for the
only positive values and then some sorry
uh even values okay so that's it for the
drawing portion uh and on to ml lib so
like scikit-learn ml lib supports a lot
of common machine learning algorithms
and supervised and unsupervised learning
and the advantage of the library is that
it creates very straightforward api's
for training and making predictions from
data sets so you have individual models
which train on data which is formatted
in a particular way and then you can
call prediction predict on like new
values which are formatted in the same
way as your input data does a lot of
other stuff too like comment summary
statistics hypothesis testing a bunch of
other stuff way more stuff than we have
time to cover but I think sort of the
the bread and butter functionality is in
this leg application of common
supervised and unsupervised learning
algorithms
um so just to get a little bit of a
flare the syntax here's a linear
regression example so you can create an
RDD by reading in a text file with rows
of some data and then parse that data by
mapping to another rdd the parsing
function being something that we specify
not on this page because it's generally
going to be specific to the type of
model that you're using and then in
building the model we pass our parse
data and then some parameters about how
the model should be trained to our
linear regression with SGD which would
be a stochastic gradient descent um and
so you just need to pass that data and
specify some parameters that are
specific to the model type and then
prediction works basically the same
thing as the same ways how scikit-learn
would work where you just call dot
predict on your model and pass it a
point to consider um fairly similarly
unsupervised learning so k means
creating clusters of related points
within a dataset reading some data train
pass model parameters so the number of
clusters number of iterations how we
initialize the centroids and then we can
print predictions just by calling
predict on the model that we've trained
um so that basically covers the like
surface-level introduction to all the
different moving pieces within this
stack and so I felt we'd run through
basically like an example problem which
would be like taking a classification
but with a really large data set and so
we'll build a program which will do the
classification using spark and ml lib
and talk about how we deploy that to an
AWS cluster so um for example will say
that we have a data file that looks
roughly like this so the first element
of each row will be a character that
we're trying to recognize and then all
the other columns will be features uh
the details of what those features are
don't particularly matter their features
their numeric um so a code to analyze
this and it's split over a couple slides
so in the beginning of our code will
import the dependencies so random forest
will be the model type that will use to
do the classification we'll also import
a labeled point which is a way of
parsing the data in a way that ml Lib is
and random forest is happy with and then
we'll import a spark context which will
allow us to create the r dds then at the
beginning we're basically initializing
our spark context and creating some
convenience variable function in order
to map our letters in each row to an
integer value so splitting up the data
into training and validation and
actually training our model a raw data
will read in a text file from the file
path specified which notably is on the
Hadoop distributed file system we talked
a bit earlier about the fact that this
is where spark will be pulling our data
from because the file needs to be held
in such a way that we can read it and
distribute it over the cluster and we'll
talk circle back to how we actually get
it on to the Hadoop distributed file
system in a bit um we'll make our
labeled points by using the Queen valued
function that we'd find on the last page
and then a spark
is a pretty nifty convenience method for
doing a random split on the RTD so
across all of these nodes we're choosing
a ratio of 7230 of the values on each
node of the cluster to partition either
to the training set or the test set so
that way we start with a sample of
thirty percent of our data set which is
there for validation after we've trained
on the bulk of our data um and then the
model um we will train a random forest
classifier on the training data and
specify some parameters about how that
model is trained so first you know the
number of classes there are 26
characters in the English alphabet any
metadata about the categorical features
max depth there are 16 features and so
you'd only want the tree to be able to
go 16 perhaps they're obviously aren't
you know definite values for any of your
parameters sandy model has your training
you're going to do parameter tooting
this is just what happened to work well
in this case and then a scoring an
output for our model arm so we map we
get a DD of labels which will be like
the actual values of our test data and
then we get predictions on those same
points by calling modeled up predict on
each of the test sets features so
basically we're creating our dd's with
both the actual values and the values
that our model predicted in order to get
a sense of how well our model performs
and predicting those actual values and
so labels and predictions were zipping
predictions into labels which is
basically just to create an RDD of
tuples so that we have a tuple with both
the actual value and the predicted value
for comparison um so
at this point we're going to filter out
only the values that match between
prediction and and actual output in
order to get our total correct and then
the percentage that we actually get
correct will be the number of those that
were correct divided by the total number
of points that we're looking at so I did
at this point our program is just going
to finish by by printing out that
percentage of correct values for our
model and I sort of have this comment
here to sort of loudly state like this
is obviously a sort of toy example in
that like if you're doing machine
learning practice you obviously don't
want to just like stop by knowing how
well your model does you'd probably want
to know be able to use that model so at
this point like you might either want to
write that model to in s3 bucket
possibly for example so that you can use
it in the future to actually make
predictions in some sort of application
after the end of this program so um
that's the code that we're going to run
and the data that we're going to use um
one of the barriers to actually doing
this kind of work is that getting all
the pieces of the stack set up and
working together and playing nice
together is not always trivial to do and
so I wanted to sort of finish by running
through sort of the pieces of the stack
and how we can actually get them to to
work together so we see like the whole
sort of process of running your
application um and so yeah that will
entail setting up 14 Ock locking
launching our cluster setting up the
cluster getting our files they're
getting them into the Hadoop distributed
file system and then finally running the
code on that cluster
um so for setting up flint rock um again
this part is entirely optional there are
plenty of other tools that serve this
function in the stack there's github
repo for which has good instructions for
installation and then if you configure
it'll provide you with a llamo file that
will basically ask for information about
you are AWS credentials so that you can
use that to seamlessly launch your
clusters and not have to deal with all
of the AWS stuff every time you want to
launch a new cluster and then the
commands for actually launching your
cluster once that's done are are pretty
straightforward you just launched a
cluster and it'll use your configuration
file in order to decide like how many
nodes have bigger your nodes um uh and
launch that and then by doing flint rock
log into your cluster you'll be taken to
a command-line interface for the the
master node of the cluster the next
thing we have to do if we're going to be
using ml lib ml lib has numpy as
dependency and so we'll need our
machines to actually be able to use
numpy and so will install c compiler so
that numpy can be installed and then
install numpy um getting files to the
cluster this is a context in which using
s3 makes a lot of sense because the
whole point of our problem is that we're
dealing with very large data and so um
having to upload locally to the server
cluster is not something that's going to
be particularly easy to do and so it
would be better to copy our data from an
s3 bucket and so your AWS ec2 instances
will come pre-installed with the the AWS
CLI and so you can use that to copy from
a bucket on to the local path on your
cluster and
so in this case I have a bucket called
Python epstein which I in which I have
data the data that we looked at before
as well as the code that we ran through
and so I could use this CLI to just copy
those to the local file system on the
cluster and then in order to actually be
able to read those in a spark program
they need to be accessible on the Hadoop
distributed file system so rather than
just being able to read them from the
file system on the master node we put
them on the Hadoop distributed file
system using that syntax which is just
FS put the path to your local file and
then the the path that you want to store
the mat on the on the HDFS which in this
case is just in the root directory and
after that it's just running your code
from from the HDFS and that's that's the
whole process um I yeah that's that's it
thank you now Jen questions we have
quite a bit of time for questions so
don't be shy question over there wait
yep thank you for the Girl Talk sorry
how it is to run programs that rely
moolah on on the clusters if it's not
really sure um yeah I can't say from
personal experience uh yeah sorry other
questions hi this might be too generic
and vague sorry about that but how do I
know how many cores to rent at AWS um
yeah I mean obviously that's just gonna
be a question of like uh application
details so i guess i could talk just a
bit about like the trade-offs you'd want
to make there um so the first obvious
concern is like how large is your data
set the larger your data set the more
cores or sighs of course you would want
I guess it also kind of depends on based
on like the actual contents of the
application you might be fine with
running like over a slightly longer
period of time if it's like not
something that you need to process
immediately if it's like a cron job for
example then you could either yeah if
it's like something that you don't need
immediate feedback on then you can use a
smaller number of course but yeah it's
hard to say without more like specific
details one more question over there
thank you also for that talk my question
was you mentioned repeatedly through
your talk that of course we have really
big data and in the pipeline that you
showed you just copied the data from the
pocket to your local home on the cluster
and then from there into the HDFS
distributed thing wouldn't it be better
to just pull it from the bucket into the
HDFS without the intermediate step yes
so uploading to the HDFS is kind of
misleading so the idea is basically that
like it's abstract away from you really
it's just like reading the file in a way
that is partitioned but the data doesn't
move again at that point so when the
only like actual transfer of data is
from the s3 bucket to the cluster and
that's going to be faster to do than
from locally because that's all like
internally on like Amazon's Cloud
storage but like when you're copying to
the HDFS it's kind of an abstraction
that it's a filesystem it's not actually
moving again